now North Korea's attempt to launch its
first spy satellite into spaces failed
State media says it crashed into the sea
after engine and fuel problems South
Korea has retrieved part of the
satellite the U.S says the launch
involved ballistic missile technology
which goes against U.N resolutions
Pyongyang announced earlier that it
wanted a satellite to monitor military
activity of the United States and its
allies
[Music]
[Applause]
while Sirens were heard in South Korea's
capital after the launch an emergency
alert to evacuate from homes was then
issued on mobile phones but it was
retracted 20 minutes later Souls mayor
has apologized for the confusion
I woke up to the alert it can't possibly
be a war I thought to myself and I went
back to sleep
honestly I think criticism of the launch
is unjust since North Korea is
recognized by the United Nations I think
it's important that we view its actions
with sincerity whether that is related
to satellites or national self-defense
our nation has been independent for more
than 70 years now and conflict could
destroy that I truly hope we don't
repeat such miseries
let's say now from Rob McBride who has
more from Seoul
South Korea's military has confirmed
that a salvage operation is now underway
and they've released a photographs of
what are thought to be parts of this
rocket both they and their U.S allies
would dearly love to have any part of
this rocket or indeed part of the
satellite itself to see just how far
Advanced North Korean technology has
become it has been confirmed that the
rocket failed probably within a few
minutes of its launch early Wednesday
South Korean military say they tracked
an abnormal flight path with the rocket
coming down and the sea that separates
the Korean Peninsula from China at a
point around 200 kilometers west of a
South Korean Island which would put it
about halfway between the Chinese and
South Korean coasts
unusually the North Koreans confirmed
the failure of their this rocket which
they've called the chalimar very quickly
saying that it was the second stage a
witch had malfunctioned but adding that
they would be analyzing just what went
wrong and correct those problems because
it says it wants to try to launch a
second one as soon as possible it has
made getting a military surveillance or
spy satellite one of its latest military
goals but this move has been condemned
by Japan also the National Security
councils of South Korea and the United
States because this rocket uses
ballistic missile technology which
violates un Security Council resolutions
Rob McBride Al Jazeera Seoul it says
Robert bride let's be now to Mason
Ritchie who's an associate professor of
international politics at Hancock
University of Foreign Studies joins us
now from Seoul Mason thanks for joining
us here on Al Jazeera first up what do
you make of this and what is North Korea
hoping to achieve with this
so you know my first uh takeaway from
this uh is that you know obviously uh
this space launch vehicle uh was a
failure uh but we should uh remember
that you know even when North Korea has
these failures whether they be you know
missile failures space launch vehicle
failures uh or nuclear tests uh they
don't pan out uh with the yield that
they want they still learn from them so
we shouldn't simply you know put a line
under this and say uh what you know they
failed you know what a joke uh they've
proven that they can learn from their
mistakes uh in terms of you know what it
is that they're doing you know I I think
we should take them uh mostly at their
word that they're attempting to place
military reconnaissance uh satellites at
least one and presumably several of them
over time uh into orbit so that they'll
be able to monitor uh the U.S rock
Alliance but my third takeaway is that
this is a violation of international law
and it should be treated uh seriously as
such
I have to ask about the South Korean
reaction it sounds very chaotic you'll
know more than me because you're there
evacuation orders and then oh no don't
evacuate it's all a bit of a Messer
response wasn't it
uh yeah yeah I have to say uh I like
everyone else uh here in Seoul I was
woken up at 6 29 this morning uh with
air raid sirens uh followed by messages
uh coming in uh uh sort of confusingly
uh through the the text message uh
system here the emergency warning uh
messages that's Pastor that told us to
to prepare for the elderly and the
children uh to be evacuated as it so
happens one of my children is actually
outside of Seoul on a school trip which
was of course a little bit worrisome
I've been here long enough now to
realize that one's first response to
these should always be you know to or
should generally be to question uh the
validity uh of the actual message it's
not the first time that we've had them
come through although it's the first
time in a long time so I'm a little bit
out of practice in terms of my
skepticism and that's actually a bit of
a worry because you begin to condition
people not to take them seriously when
you make multiple mistakes like this I
was gonna say I mean it's two things
isn't it it shows how Twitchy the
authorities are and also next time will
people take it seriously if and it could
be a a threat
yeah if if there is a serious threat and
people are conditioned uh to ask
questions first and not to follow the
orders to to evacuate or to to shelter
and safety uh you know that difference
between seconds and minutes could you
know for some people make the difference
between life and death so it's something
that they should definitely uh review
and I think that they will uh you know
they'll take this seriously I think and
try to make sure they get it right going
forward
uh Mason great security perspective
appreciate that Mason Ritchie associate
professor of international politics at
Hancock University thank you great thank
you